what are your thoughts about what
happens pre birth and post death oh
that's fun pre birth I haven't spent a
lot of time on pre birth but I know post
death we're still connected so that is a
really I just know we are because I and
I didn't I wasn't a hundred percent sure
until my mom died and she she left us
with this giant rainbow spectacular
rainbow that came from nowhere and and
all of a sudden there was this
spectacular rainbow and I thought
because we were all sort of flipping out
we had just lost her mother and just by
going outside all of a sudden we saw
this spectacular rainbow and we've seen
there have been other sort of
interesting signs I won't go into all of
them there is more and I think that
after that at first they they want to
make sure like when people die they want
to make sure that everything goes
according to their plan and after that I
think they have another adventure and so
that over time they they move on to
their other adventures so I think there
is more and I don't know whether the two
things are linked whether you you know
if you do well here you do well there
but I do know that we're connected I
also believe that we're interconnected
with each other throughout the world how
many times have you thought of somebody
and then seen them at the grocery store
about an hour later that kind of thing
we are all interconnected so there are
all of these there may be neurons firing
in here and there may be by the way your
gut actually actually does have a brain
to it and so your brain and your gut not
only are in this body but they are also
connected with all these other bodies we
are interconnected where we're actually
connected with the plants and animals
too and I think those connections are
not as
not as strong but they are there and and
then the before birth could be that
adventure you were talking about the
next they could be in a previous
adventure no previous adventure to this
next I mean what's interesting is I
don't know if other people have felt
this but I have felt that I would get
some new piece of educational material
and I'll look at it and I'll go I
already know this and I know it's new to
my life but I already know it I'm not
sure why that is or how that happened
but I already know it so I think that
there are things that that connect from
previous life to now and from now to
future life and so I'm you know after my
mom died all of a sudden I realized hey
it's okay yeah it's okay we're this is
just a part of a longer much more
extraordinary adventure and story
yeah and then there's something I always
like to sort of throw out to my students
and to other people look up at the stars
and realize that you're just on this
little marble flying through space pearl
like look up at the stars and then and
then think how amazing how many stars
there are and all that think of is there
an end to that and then you think wait
if there's an end what are you boxed in
how does that work or is there no end to
that and both are equally freaky to
think about